oi meu nome é isabela e hoje vou falar
pra vocês um pouco sobre a campanha do
lacre
aposto que muitos de vocês já conhecem
essa campanha muitos podem até achar que
ela não existe apenas uma lenda urbana
mas é sobre isso que eu vou falar com
vocês
a campanha do acre é uma campanha que
arrecada lacres pra que arrecada lacres
para trocar com empresas por cadeira de
rodas
muitas pessoas que eu falei no começo
pensava que essa campanha não existia
mas ela existe sim porque foi provado é
que ela existe e estabelecendo muitas
pessoas mas como podemos ajudar você
pode utilizar da seguinte forma 1º e
esvaziar uma garrafa pet de dois litros
lave e seque bem e deixe totalmente
limpa
depois de tomar qualquer bebida numa
lata de metal retire seu lacre e guarde
na garrafa
faça isso até que a garrafa fique cheia
de lacres quando não houver mais espaço
faça tudo de novo
mas não é apenas uma garrafa cheia de
lacres que vai conseguir uma cadeira de
rodas
precisamos de 120 garrafas cheias de
lacres para conseguir uma cadeira de
rodas há muito não é então ativa e seus
familiares amigos filhos vizinhos a
participarem dessa campanha
obrigada